c'est l'une des pires catastrophes
naturelles de l'histoire de l'humanité
le Pakistan frappé par des inondations
gigantesques au moins 1600 morts 7
millions de déplacés des dégâts estimé
la fourchette est large entre 18 et 30
milliards de dollars un carnage
climatique comme l'a dit le secrétaire
général des Nations unies sommes-nous
entrer dans l'air des méga catastrophes
peut-on parler d'injustice climatique
pour les pays les plus pauvres on en
débat dans une minute mais d'abord
l'état des lieux avec Gaspard flamand
ici à méhard dans le sud du Pakistan on
ne distingue plus que le haut des
minarets de cette mosquée qui émergent
dans la créé par les inondations et qui
s'étend sur des dizaines de kilomètres
de long des volontaires de la marine
parcourent les eaux sur des bateaux de
sauvetage pour apporter de l'aide aux
habitants dans la détresse car les
pluies continuent et la situation de
s’améliore pas nous ne vivons pas ici
par choix tout ce que nous possédons est
sous l'eau tout a été emporté par les
eaux nous sommes obligés de vivre ici
nous sommes piégés
depuis le mois de juin 1600 personnes
ont perdu la vie dans ses violentes
d'inondations 13.000 sont blessés en
cause des pluies de moussons les pires
qui est connu le pays depuis des
dizaines d’années en plus du bilan
humain le bilan matériel est aussi lourd
avec un tiers du pays touché 2 millions
d'habitations et 7000 km de route sont
détruites dépend entier de terres
agricoles vit à l'emporter devant l'ONU
le Premier ministre pakistanais assure
que ces inondations ne sont qu'un
prélude nous vivons actuellement une
mousson sans précédent c'est
littéralement une mousse ont sous
stéroïde comme le secrétaire général des
Nations unies la décrit de manière très
appropriée elle est sous stéroïde une
chose est très claire ce qu'il s'est
passé au Pakistan ne restera pas
cantonné au Pakistan
face à cette situation l'OMS a placé le
pays sur son plus haut échelon d’alerte
car avec des dizaines de millions
d'habitants qui vivent dans des
conditions épouvantables les risques
d'apparition de maladies liées au son
démultipliées après sa visite au
Pakistan au début du mois le Secrétaire
Général des Nations en appel à la
solidarité internationale et craint un
avenir de chaos permanent et omniprésent
s'agisse du Pakistan de la Corne de
l'Afrique du Sahel des petites îles ou
des pays les moins développées les
personnes les plus vulnérables du monde
qui n'ont rien fait pour provoquer cette
crise paie un prix horrible pour des
décennies d'intransigeance de la part
des grands émetteurs les pays du G20
sont responsables de 80% des émissions
le gouvernement pakistanais estime que
10 milliards de dollars sont nécessaires
à la reconstruction du pays en
particulier pour les télécommunications
les routes et l'agriculture
je vous présente tout de suite les
invités de ce second débat dans le sens
public Françoise vueux bonsoir bienvenue
vous êtes climatologue directrice de
recherche à l'Institut de Recherche pour
le Développement Léa Falco membres de
l'association pour un réveil écologique
bonsoir bienvenue Bienvenue également à
Gilles boquera bonsoir vous êtes
chercheur associé à la Fondation pour la
recherche stratégique spécialiste de
l'Asie du Sud et hauteur de cet ouvrage
le Pakistan en 100 questions publiée aux
éditions Talandier et évidemment
Laetitia Rupa est resté à mes côtés je
vous fais réagir tiens sur une des
formules qu'on a entendu dans dans le
sujet instant de Gaspard flamand une
mousse en sous stéroïde est-ce que vous
diriez ça vous aussi alors j'avais pas
pensé jusqu'à la prochaine à parler
comme ça mais c'est un peu ça en fait
parce que c'est vraiment une mousson
exceptionnelle d'abord on a une
variabilité d'une année à l'autre très
forte dans cette région là pour les
moussons les plus moussons cette mousse
on a été exacerbée aussi parce que on a
une situation la Nina vous savez ces
phénomènes à ninio la ninia qu'on
connaît dans le Pacifique équatorial
cette année on a une situation la Nina
c'est à dire on a des autres surfaces
dans le Pacifique équatorial assez
froide et ça ça un impact sur tout le
climat de la région tropicale et en
particulier sur les régimes depuis et
donc sur les moussons et ça vient
exacerber en fait les moussons et puis
on a eu des pluies en fait au mois
d'août particulièrement intense depuis
de quelques jours avec des cumuls
journaliers vraiment exceptionnels sur
le Pakistan donc là vraiment une mousson
hyper boostée moi c'était le mot que
j'avais et c'est ce qui permet d'une
certaine façon de dire que c'est une
catastrophe d'une ampleur inédite pour
pour le pays parce que c'est un pays qui
est malheureusement qui a déjà vécu des
innovations gravissime oui alors en fait
les comme je le disais les moussons sont
vraiment très variables c'est-à-dire que
les les elles se succèdent d'une année à
l'autre mais elles peuvent être très
différentes mais là on a vraiment des
cumules de pluie entre mi-juin et août
qui sont exceptionnels par exemple sur
le mois d'août si on regarde sur
l'ensemble du pays les plus sont
multipliés par 3 par rapport à ce qu'on
attend d'habitude et sur le sud en fait
du Pakistan c'est multiplié par 7 8 avec
des événements extrêmes très ponctuels
et donc c'est vraiment le couplage entre
des puits permanentes entre mi-juin et
fin août et des événements extrêmes
depuis qui ont conduit à ces inondations
alors justement on va vous regarder
ensemble une carte du Pakistan pour bien
prendre conscience de l'ampleur de de la
catastrophe que vous voyez en on va dire
en rose c'est toutes les régions les
provinces qui ont été touchées je vais
citer les plus importantes le bel outil
stand le Penjab et puis surtout la
province de sind j'espère que ma
prononciation est correcte ça sont des
chiffres de fin août 5 millions 800 000
personnes déplacées plus de 1 million 11
hectares de surface cultivées affectées
au total dans le pays on parle de 33
millions de personnes touchées par les
inondations ça représente un habitant
sur cette Gilles boquera il faut
peut-être dresser le tableau de ce
qu'est le Pakistan c'est aussi à la
dimension de ce pays qui est l'un des
plus peuplés du monde oui effectivement
c'est le cinquième pays le plus peuplé
au monde et il faut un peu compter de
studié cette crise humanité avec les
mathématique actuelle c'est le fait faut
le relier au fait que le pays traverse
une crise politique depuis la que le
Imran Kahn a perdu la confiance du
Parlement avec un nouveau gouvernement
et mannequin n'a qu'une obsession c'est
revenir au pouvoir donc quitte à
déstabiliser le gouvernement actuel ce
qui fait que la classe politique est
préoccupée pas seulement par ses
inondations encore une fois qui sont
historiques et catastrophiques il y a
une crise économique là c'est évidemment
le covid la guerre en Ukraine qui fait
de s'arranger considérablement le prix
des matières premières
une inflation très forte dans le pays et
ensuite il y a une crise financière il
faut savoir qu'en début d'année le pays
était au bord de la station de paiement
le réserve de change couvrait à peine 6
semaines d'importation donc le Pakistan
traverse actuellement un cumul de crise
conjuguée qui font que le pays traverse
une phase extrêmement difficile donc ça
explique aussi l'ampleur de l'ampleur
social de la catastrophe d'une certaine
façon c'est ce que vous nous dites oui
bah faut savoir que déjà il y a d'après
les chiffres officiels il y a plus de 2
millions d'habitants qui ont perdu leur
logement ces populations sont déplacées
dans des campes fortunes avec les
risques d'épidémie afférents
paludisme dingue diarrhée parce qu'il
est très difficile de trouver de l'eau
potable par exemple qui vient par
container
encore une fois on est face à un pays
qui si on suit l'indice de développement
humain
de la Banque mondiale et 161e au niveau
mondial 7 12 pays répertoriés donc on
est face à un pays déjà du Sud pauvre
qui n'a pas forcément les moyens
financiers de réponse à cette crise
c'est pour ça qu'elle fait appel à
l'aide internationale et on va y venir
évidemment en détail les Falco on parle
souvent de d'injustice climatique on
peut dire que cette catastrophe elle
illustre bien cette notion pourquoi
c'est en fait exactement ce qu'on vient
d'entendre c'est que le les crises
climatiques en général comme on sait
qu'elles sont plus fortes dans des pays
qui sont qui ont une moindre résilience
et en particulier les pays des sud ou
les pays en développement et ben c'est
que elle s'ajoutent à des crises qui
sont déjà en place des crises politiques
des crises économiques des crises
sanitaires parfois et que par conséquent
c'est une couche de plus sur ces pays-là
qui n'en fait en cumulé et actuellement
ne représente qu'une très faible
proportion des émissions de Gabriel
j'ai trouvé ces chiffres donc la
population pakistanaise après 3% la
population mondiale responsable de 0,8%
à peine 1% des émissions mondiales de
gaz à effet de oui c'est pas surprenant
vous avez de toute façon le vous avez
deux grands enjeux sur le l'action sur
le réchauffement climatique vous avez
l'adaptation et vous avez l'atténuation
l'atténuation qui va être la baisse des
émissions de gaz à effetr qui donc va
être surtout quelque chose sur lequel
nous vont se concentrer les pays
émetteurs même si il faut quand même
rappeler que les pays qui mettent moins
de 1 % des émissions mondiales c'est 200
pays en tout donc il va falloir aussi
évidemment que ces pays six mètres mais
vous avez surtout aussi des enjeux
d'adaptation qui sont donc d'adaptation
des infrastructures des modes de vie des
sociétés qui sont pas toujours adaptées
et qui dans le cas de pays comme le
Pakistan ne le sont pas du tout pour se
mettre à niveau de catastrophe
conjoncturelle qui vont arriver et qui
vont être de différents types parce que
il y a ces inondations mais il va y
avoir aussi au Pakistan par exemple des
canicules il y a eu c'était au Pakistan
et en Inde en l'espace de trois mois
vous avez eu des canicules quasi mortels
donc c'est à dire où vous avez une
conjonction de température et d'humidité
qui rendent impossible à transpiration
et qui est donc peuvent être
potentiellement létales et quelques
semaines plus tard vous avez eu ces
inondations de moussons donc vous allez
avoir un panel assez large quand même
d'événements climatiques extrêmes
auxquelles vont devoir s'adapter ces
pays-là et la question du financement et
on va y revenir je pense assez largement
et évidemment essentiel là-dedans
évidemment elle est majeure cette
question Françoise Vimeu quelle est la
part du changement climatique parce que
voilà c'est c'est une vraie question il
y a des moyens scientifiques de de
l'évaluer expliquer nous oui alors en
fait quand il y a des événements
extrêmes comme saisie inondations comme
les vagues fin de la vague de chaleur
qui a connu le Pakistan là au début du
printemps qui était vraiment
complètement exceptionnel il y a ce
qu'on appelle des études d'attribution
donc en fait on regarde si un événement
extrême que l'on connaît ce serait
produit dans un climat non modifié par
l'homme et est-ce que sa probabilité a
changé et si cet événement s'était
produit dans un climat non modifié
est-ce qu'il aurait été aussi intense
alors sur la canicule puisqu'on en a
parlé du début du printemps les études
ont montré qu'elle a été rendue 30 fois
plus probable par le changement
climatique et de manière globale on sait
que la plupart des vagues de chaleur que
l'on ressent aujourd'hui sont rendus
beaucoup plus probables par le
changement climatique sur le territoire
hexagonal celle de juillet 2019 aurait
été quasiment impossible sans changement
climatique pour revenir sur les
inondations donc il y a une étude
d'attribution qui vient juste d'être
réalisée c'est complexe c'est complexe
pour les puits parce que les modèles de
climat ont des difficultés à représenter
les régimes depuis dans les régions
tropicales donc entre guillemets pour
faire simple on n'est pas forcément
aider en revanche ce que montre quand
même ces modèles c'est que quand on
regarde les pluies intenses sur quelques
jours on voit très bien que ces pluies
intenses elles sont de plus en plus
intenses au fur et à mesure que le
Pakistan se réchauffe donc l'attribution
elle montre que le cumul journalier de
ces pluies pendant les moussons augmente
et reliés certainement très probablement
au changement climatique alors on va
parler des infrastructures effectivement
maintenant dans dans ce débat je donnais
le chiffre tout à l'heure la fourchette
elle est elle est large on parle de d'un
coup de destruction évaluée entre 18 et
30 milliards de dollars et donc ces
inondations elles ont ravagé beaucoup
d'infrastructures et provoquer aussi
cette réaction du Secrétaire général des
Nations unies en tenue gouttes c'était
lors d'une visite sur place au Pakistan
le 17 septembre écoutez
dans le monde mais je n'ai jamais vu de
carnage climatique de cette ampleur
carnage climatique évidemment la formule
à frapper les esprits Gilles boquera je
voudrais qu'on rentre un peu dans le
détail des infrastructures du pays où
vous nous avez décrit le contexte
politique mais est-ce que l'ampleur de
la catastrophe elle s'explique aussi par
l'état des infrastructures d'un pays
pauvre comme le Pakistan oui bah il y a
un organisme qui était supposé gérer
d'organismes national et la gestion des
catastrophes justement qui a été créée
en 2007 après le séisme encore une fois
c'est un autre problème du Pakistan
c'est il est aussi mis aussi séisme sa
partie malienne ce temps
en 2010 je rappelle qu'il y a eu des
très forts Pakistan pas comparable à
celle de cette année mais qui a déjà
très importante très coûteuse pour le
pays une chute de la croissance
économique a été quasiment divisée par
deux en 2011 suite aux inondations 2010
encore une fois effectivement là encore
le problème c'est aussi pour la
cheminement des secours en fait pour
porter secours aux personnes qui sont
actuellement sous les eaux en fait ça
pose un réel problème les chemins de fer
les routes tout a été touché par ses
inondations encore une fois un tiers du
pays a été sous les eaux
et on peut estimer que la des crues va
prendre
au moins deux mois et peut-être jusqu'à
six mois et ça crée le problème aussi de
des récoltes évidemment
pourquoi ça prend pardon je joue une
parenthèse pourquoi ça prend autant de
temps la décrue il y a un aquarium un
aspect un peu de cuvette au Pakistan je
veux juste essayer de comprendre je sais
pas si vous avez la réponse scientifique
mais
non mais il faut encore une fois le le
Pakistan a traversé par l'Indus en fait
du nord au sud du pays ça crée il y a
plein de l'Indus qui est effectivement
notamment à être le système de canaux
créé par les Anglais c'est un peu le
grenier à blé et céréales du pays et
c'est cette région et des Patriots
infectée bien cohésie cette fois-ci et
aussi le signe et baochistan
qui ont été touchés alors que par
exemple il y a un an et en partie le
signe on parlait de sécheresse donc
d'une année sur l'autre on passe de
sécheresse d'épisode de sécheresse à des
inondations catastrophiques et encore
une fois le pays c'est ce que je disais
tout à l'heure est un pays du Sud qui
n'a pas les moyens d'avoir les
structures de prévention à mettre en
place pour anticiper ce genre de
catastrophes Léa Falco donc on parle des
infrastructures des pays pauvres qui
sont forcément moins adaptés moins
résilientes face aux risques climatiques
c'est ça l'idée c'est non seulement
c'est l'idée mais de la réalité c'est
assez documenté on a quand même et vous
avez effectivement ce problème de pas
avoir les ressources financières en
interne et donc d'avoir une coopération
internationale qui est nécessaire sur
ces questions là parce que on en a parlé
un justice climatique le Pakistan est
classé par une ONG allemande comme 8e
rang des pays qui peuvent être le plus
impactés donc qui ont le plus de risques
de subir c'est événements climatiques
extrêmes et diversifiés parce que c'est
aussi ça qu'il faut retenir dans le cas
du Pakistan c'est que ça va de
sécheresse à l'inondation
c'est toute la difficulté c'est qu'ils
sont tout le panel et que donc ça
demande des structures qui sont
forcément extrêmement spécifiques mais
ça dans tous les pays des suites par
ailleurs il faut nécessairement que les
adaptations soient spécifiques aux
enjeux endémiques et locaux mais
effectivement vous avez cette question
de la coopération internationale
financière et donc en 2010 vous aviez un
impact qui avait lié les pays développés
et en particulier les pays du G20 pour
apporter 100 milliards d'euros par an au
pays en développement d'ici 2020 en 2020
on était à peu près 83 milliards et les
difficultés effectivement développement
c'est à dire à combien de pays en je
crois que c'était 120 il faut que je
vérifie les chiffres mais c'était une
grande partie des pays 80% grosso modo
vous dites 83 milliards sur les 100
milliards qui ont été distribués
absolument qui était du financement
public et du financement privé mais il
faut aussi voir les conditions dans
lesquelles ils sont octroyés et c'est
aussi toute la difficulté c'est que vous
avez un certain nombre qui sont des qui
sont des dons vous avez à peu près 30 %
qui était des dons mais vous aviez
beaucoup de prêt qui du coup sont fixés
à des taux qui sont pas toujours des
taux très favorables pour ces pays-là et
qui les incidents parfois à prendre des
politiques intérieures pas
nécessairement les plus adaptés à la
situation et vous avez aussi en interne
et c'est toute la difficulté dans le cas
du développement international des des
politiques des catégories des classes
politiques sur place qui ne font pas
toujours le meilleur usage de sergent là
et donc c'est toute la différence parce
que au Pakistan et vous dire les mots on
peut parler de détournement
Pakistan et dans un certain nombre de
pays des Sud à cause justement du manque
de résilience politique aussi des
infrastructures humaines entre
guillemets c'est justement la question
que je voulais vous poser peut-être à
vous à vous monsieur la nature du régime
du Pakistan n'empêche pas d'une certaine
manière les aides l'intérieur de venir
on se précipite pas pour aider le
Pakistan vu la nature du régime
islamiste peut-être que Gilles Bocquet a
peut répondre à cette question non je
parlais pas je parlerai pas de régime
islamiste tout de même le gouvernement
actuel
il y a un processus démocratique pour
pour qui amène le choix du Premier
ministre maintenant c'est vrai que
l'image du Pakistan n'est pas très bonne
en Occident notamment parce
qu'effectivement c'est associé au
mouvement des talibans en Afghanistan et
même mouvement des talibans pakistanais
il y a eu la fière des caricatures il y
a pas si longtemps en 2019
ou la France d'ailleurs a été pointée du
doigt ce qui a entraîné le fait que
pendant trois ans il y a eu à chargé
d'affaires ambassade du Pakistan à Paris
et pas l'ambassadeur
donc c'est vrai que le Pakistan bénéfice
pas d'une image forcément très positive
ça explique aussi probablement pourquoi
on se précipite pas ceci dit je veux
mention je fais que le président Macron
a rencontré sont le premier ministre
pakistanais Washington chaba Sharif et
la France a proposé d'organiser une
conférence internationale des donateurs
d'ici la fin de l'année alors on y
reviendra sur ce la diplomatie de la
catastrophe en quelque sorte parce qu'il
y a aussi ça dans dans dans ce qu'on vit
depuis des semaines au Pakistan et c'est
assez passionnant à décoder mais je
voudrais rester sur cette question des
infrastructures avec vous Françoise
Vimeux alors c'est peut-être une
évidence mais je voudrais qu'on la
détaille un peu si on compare des
inondations dans un pays comme le
Pakistan ou alors aux États-Unis en ce
moment il y a alors je sais pas si c'est
un cyclone je crois que c'est le terme
voilà le psy a plein de termes
différents qui font cyclos de tornade
donc c'est un cyclone c'est ça bon
encore une fois c'est une évidence mais
un pays pourquoi les infrastructures
d'un pays riche résistent beaucoup mieux
quoi s'il faut quand même l'expliquer un
peu en détail alors je pense que ce
qu'il faut il faut rappeler c'est que le
risque c'est gouverné par trois aspects
d'abord vous avez l'aléa climatique donc
c'est des pluies torrentiels c'est un
cyclone à nous qui passe vous avez
ensuite l'exposition là au Pakistan on
avait des plaines inondables où vous
trouviez des habitants donc des
habitations des infrastructures telles
que des routes des ponts des écoles des
établissements de santé des cultures la
culture du coton vous trouviez aussi le
bétail etc donc il y avait une énorme
exposition à l'aléa de l'inondation et
puis la différence en fait avec entre
pays du Nord et pays du Sud c'est le
troisième aspect c'est la vulnérabilité
et vous l'avez très bien dit on a vu ce
matin en tout cas j'ai vu ce matin des
photos terrifiantes de submersion marine
en Floride et pourtant il va y avoir
uniquement des dégâts matériels pourquoi
parce que c'est un état qui est organisé
il y a eu une alerte il y a quelques
jours les gens se sont déplacés ils
savent se déplacer mais où aller ce qui
est pas forcément le cas au Pakistan
d'abord il y a pas forcément un système
d'alerte ensuite les gens bah se
déplacent mais s'il se déplacent à 10 km
ça change pas grand chose et donc c'est
là la différence c'est la vulnérabilité
moi je pense que c'est le mot clé entre
pays du Nord et pays du Sud c'est pas
forcément l'aléa climatique l'alléa
climatique touche aujourd'hui tous les
territoires
presque aussi durement les uns que les
autres les États-Unis le Pakistan
certains vont être moins touchés mais
c'est pas forcément des pays du Sud
c'est pas forcément des pays du Nord
mais c'est la manière dont on va gérer
notre vulnérabilité la manière dont
c'est déjà adapté et ça c'est c'est très
important et effectivement il y a
l'adaptation est pas extraordinaire dans
nos pays européens mais au moins elle
existe pour partie et le d'exemple des
États-Unis je trouve est très parlant de
ce point de vue là Gilles bouclerc la
prévention c'est c'est presque un luxe
de pays riches on pourrait dire ça comme
ça oui tout à fait ça coûte cher ça
coûte cher comme je disais tout à
l'heure le pays traverse une crise
financière ils ont enfin obtenu un
déblocage d'une tranche auprès du FMI
récemment très récemment il demande
d'ailleurs une nouvelle tranche un
nouvel E3 de prêt
encore une fois c'est c'est des aléas
mais qu'on rencontre aussi on a un je
veux dire il y a pas très longtemps
bungalow qui est pourtant le siège de
l'informatique indienne la ville était
était sous les eaux c'est vrai aussi
dans le nord-est de l'Inde on a ça moi
seulement il y a eu des inondations
catastrophique donc il s'est un
phénomène qui touche toute l'Asie du Sud
qui est pas seulement limitée au
Pakistan mais encore une fois
effectivement
c'est ça coûte cher de de une politique
de prévention et c'est un pays qui en a
pas vraiment vraiment le luxe alors vous
nous disiez la vie du Sud-Est
particulièrement touché on va évoquer la
question maintenant des réfugiés
climatiques et je propose à atteindre la
nuit de de nous rejoindre rebonsoir Tam
avec des des données donc sur les
conséquences humaines de ces
catastrophes naturelles en Asie du
Sud-Est justement et oui ces 10
dernières années entre 2010 et 2021
exactement et bien il y a eu 225
millions de personnes qui sont devenues
réfugiés climatiques dans cette région
d'Asie Pacifique c'est la région du
globe qui comporte le plus de déplacés
pour ces raisons et encore les chiffres
sont en deçà de la réalité puisque cette
étude n'a pas pu prendre en compte et
bien ce dont vous parliez à l'instant
c'est-à-dire les récentes inondations au
Pakistan si l'on regarde les pays les
plus touchés ces 10 dernières années on
va trouver sur ce triste podium et bien
d'abord la Chine avec 70 millions de
déplacés les Philippines 50 millions de
déplacés et enfin l'Inde 41 millions de
déplacés là encore ces 10 dernières
années l'étude qui a fourni ces chiffres
a été réalisé par la Banque asiatique de
développement et l'idmc un institut
norvégien qui a compilé toutes les
données en matière de déplacement
climatique est-ce que les inondations
représentent la première cause de
déplacement de population oui elles sont
à l'origine de près de la moitié des
déplacements avec
113,6 millions de personnes qui ont été
frappées en raison d'inondation on va
avoir des images les images des
inondations de 2010 en Chine rien que
cette année-là 15 millions de Chinois
ont dû fuir les inondations en cause les
pluies diluviennent de la mousson les
typhons les tempêtes qui se sont
aggravées en fréquence en intensité avec
le réchauffement climatique le rapport
met aussi en cause plus directement et
bien des facteurs d'origine humaine
alors l'urbanisation rapide dans cette
région du monde ce sont les mots du
rapport et selon les projections de
l'étude 18 millions de personnes par an
sont susceptibles être de d'être
déplacés à cause d'inondation 80% de ces
personnes vivent en région
urbaine ou périurbaines ça se comprend
aussi puisque beaucoup de villes sont
situées en région côtière ou encore à
proximité de fleuves enfin le rapport
met aussi en cause la construction de
grands barrages en Asie du Sud-Est qui
ont rendu les pays plus vulnérables aux
inondations c'est le cas pour les pays
le long du Mékong Cambodge Laos Myanmar
shint Island ou encore Vietnam donc des
êtres humains mais aussi on l'a évoqué à
propos du Pakistan des astres économique
pour ces pays qui demandent à être
indemnisés oui qui doit payer pour
l'Impact catastrophique des ouragans des
inondations des feux de forêt etc les
pays en développement sont les plus
touchés sont les plus vulnérables vous
le disiez ils se sont les plus touchés
par les conséquences du réchauffement
climatique ils sont les moins
responsables ils réclament donc une aide
un mécanisme de financement au pays du
Nord les pays du Nord ils ont eu promis
une aide 200 milliards de dollars par an
à destination des pays du Sud or pour
l'instant bien le compte n'y est pas en
2020 ils ont mobilisé 80 milliards de
dollars seulement et ce sujet des
financements et bien le cristallise de
nombreuses tensions à l'approche de la
cop27 la Coop qui aura lieu en Égypte au
mois de novembre prochain oui merci
pour être précis effectivement ces
chiffres ont les données tout à l'heure
avec avec vous non non il y a aucun
problème c'est c'est moi je pense qu'il
faut souvent répéter pour que les
messages
passent qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce qui peut
se jouer là cette cop27 qu'est-ce qu'on
peut en attendre sur cette question
précise finalement de d'une sorte de de
redistribution ou de solidarité des pays
les plus riches envers les pays les plus
pauvres qui je le rappelle ont un impact
carbone qui est faible et qui sont
souvent en première ligne dans les dans
les catastrophes climatiques bah ce sera
déjà quelque chose qui se joue pas le
jour de la Coop 27 d'accord c'est des
processus qui prennent du temps en fait
parce que le décidé faire une jolie
photo où c'est dans 40 jours non mais
c'est sur plusieurs années c'est
d'ailleurs c'est plus sûr plusieurs
décennies parce qu'en fait c'est des les
processus coopératifs ils se font à
partir des banques de développement de
chaque pays en coopération avec les
bandes de développement locales
nationales et et international donc
c'est quelque chose qui de toute façon
ne va pas être solutionné par le fait
que une quarantaine de dirigeants
prennent une jolie photo en costard mais
c'est important qu'on ait des échéances
comme ça aussi pour remettre le sujet
sur la table là il y a une idée qui est
en train de sortir pour et qui a priori
va se réaliser pour la COP 27 de faire
une feuille de route un échéancier une
forme d'échéancier des financements
destiné au pays des Suds ça c'est
quelque chose qui typiquement et
important parce que avec ça vous pouvez
aussi typolog réaliser les endroits en
tout cas la manière dont vous ciblez vos
financements et là actuellement sur les
100 milliards dans votre journaliste
parlait il y en a à peu près et qui de
fait son que 80 milliards par an il y en
a à peu près un tiers seulement qui est
consacré à l'adaptation donc ça veut
dire que deux tiers sont envoyées vers
l'aténation donc la réduction des
émissions de gaz à effetr ce qui n'a en
fait pour un grand nombre de ces pays
pas le l'enjeu premier il vaut mieux
flécher cet argent c'est après il va
falloir réussir à atteindre la
coopération optimale ce qui n'est pas
simple du tout et pas seulement pour
l'enjeu climatique avec les pays en
développement pour réussir à trouver la
manière d'utiliser au mieux cet argent
là c'est toujours le la question qui
revient si on est un peu cynique et là
je reviens à la question des réfugiés
climatiques c'est aussi l'intérêt des
pays du Nord des pays les plus riches de
faire en sorte qu'il y ait pas autant de
réfugiés climatiques dans les prochaines
décennies c'est qu'il y a pas ça qui
rentre aussi en un petit peu mais je
pense que vraiment c'est pas le c'est
pas l'enjeu principal pour eux parce que
la plupart des réfugiés climatiques
seront des réfugiés locaux donc c'est à
dire qu'il va ils vont pas aussi loin
ils vont pas aller aussi loin justement
les 33 millions
pakistanais qui sont réfugiés ils sont
où peut-être que Gilles BOC ils sont
réfugiés dans des camps notamment un
Karachi qui ont été créés pour les
accueillir
climatique ça peut être des processus
très longs aussi dans le temps enfin le
prendre la décision de quitter un pays
il faut peut-être que je sais pas je
réfléchis un peu tout mais plusieurs
catastrophes enchaînées pour que
finalement une famille se dise on va
quitter notre pays je suis pas du tout
spécialiste des processus psychologiques
qui mènent à se cette décision là mais
le fait que ce soit local est quand même
important parce que on a l'impression
aujourd'hui en Europe et c'est propagé
par un certain nombre de discours aussi
partisans aujourd'hui que suite au
réchauffement climatique vous allez
avoir une une armada de réfugiés
climatique qui est un terme qui par
ailleurs est difficilement quantifiable
juridiquement et qui donc va poser des
problèmes au juriste dans les prochaines
années de réfugiés climatiques qui vont
arriver en Europe alors qu'en fait la
répartition sera dans les pays
environnants et dans les pays même donc
ça va juste être des relocalisations de
ces gens là qui vont subir ces
catastrophes et ça va être des flux qui
vont pour la grande majorité de Paris en
Europe et par ailleurs les réfugiés
seront ceux qui auront réussi à le faire
donc ça veut dire que vous avez quand
même un certain nombre de personnes qui
vont mourir à cause de ces conséquences
là et en particulier dans des pays qui
sont très peu adaptés donc vous avez
vraiment cet jeu là de se rendre compte
de ce fait là et de pouvoir aussi
adapter en fonction de la vulnérabilité
non seulement
international c'est à dire de la du pays
mais aussi des individus à l'intérieur
de ce pays là et donc de fléchir vers
les plus modestes ces solutions là oui
en fait sur les réfugiés climatiques je
crois que les sols réfugiés qui vont
quitter leur territoire c'est ceux qui
partent qui quittent les petites îles
les États insulaires à cause de la
montée du niveau des mers et puis des
submersions marines et donc des
inondations qui peuvent arriver sachant
que c'est bête à dire mais quand vous
êtes sur une île vous êtes entouré d'eau
et donc si ça monte et bien vous avez
pas d'autres choix que de partir et ce
qui vient d'être dit et tout à fait vrai
il va y avoir des relocalisations très
très locales ce qui veut dire que ce
sera aussi des localisations des
relocalisations pardon qui ne sont pas
forcément pérennes entre guillemets et
donc on va avoir un peu des nomades du
changement climatique et je trouve que
c'est particulièrement
problématique parce que qui dit nomade
dit des conditions de vie qui sont quand
même particulièrement difficiles
peut-être plus difficile que ce qu'elles
étaient auparavant mais alors si on
change de continent si on parle du
continent africain vous nous dites que
il va pas y avoir plus de réfugiés venez
alors je suis pas en train de reprendre
le discours d'une certaine partie de la
classe politique mais c'est quand même
certainement une question que les
téléspectateurs se pose il va pas y
avoir plus de réfugiés venant de ces
pays
d'Afrique d'Afrique du Nord ou d'Afrique
saharienne à cause de à cause des
conditions climatiques je peux pas vous
donner le chiffre précis je suis pas
spécialiste des migrations non plus je
suis pas spécialiste de grand chose je
vous l'accorde c'est un vrai c'est une
vraie question quand même parce que
j'entends le discours considéral ne ne
ne agitons pas les les peurs sur ces
questions des réfugiés climatiques mais
il y a peut-être une réalité qui est
différente d'un continent à l'autre
aussi certainement mais en tout cas les
chiffres de la Banque mondiale montrent
que je crois que c'est les deux tiers ou
les trois quarts des réfugiés vont être
des réfugiés locaux donc les pays qui
dans les pays qui sont directement
limitrophes d'accord et vous avez un car
qui vont aller plus loin que ces pays
limitrophes et donc il potentiellement
effectivement pour arriver dans des pays
comme l'Europe mais comme les États-Unis
comme la Chine donc vous avez vous avez
des enjeux qui sont vraiment de ne pas
subsistance
les gens vont aller dans des endroits où
ils ont des liens culturels quelconque
que ce soit la langue que ce soit de la
famille que ce soit des diasporas c'est
à ça que ça va se résumer à un moment ou
un autre Françoise vimeule cette liste
là des astrueuse quoi des pays les plus
les plus vulnérables face aux
changements climatiques donc il y a le
Pakistan vous nous avez dit en huitième
position c'est alors moi j'ai une vision
un peu plus un peu plus macro c'est à
dire que on sait que dans la bande
tropicale subtropicale je crois que ça
ça a été dit on va avoir des des
conditions potent vraiment mortel
lorsque l'on va avoir des conditions
couplées de température extrêmes donc
des vagues de chaleur et des humidités
particulièrement élevées on sait passer
au Pakistan ces derniers temps
quand il fait très très chaud en même
temps c'est il fait très très chaud et
en plus vous avez un taux d'humidité
très élevé donc ça empêche votre corps
de se refroidir par la transpiration
parce que la transpiration ça crée une
évaporation l'évaporation ça vous
refroidit comme quand vous sortez de
votre douche et on sait par exemple
qu'aujourd'hui on est sur des
trajectoires de réchauffement qui nous
emmènent à aux alentours de 3 degrés à
la fin du 21e siècle et on sait que dans
ces conditions et bien le Pakistan une
partie de l'Inde du Bangladesh subissent
par an plusieurs dizaines de jours où on
a des conditions potentiellement
mortelles à cause de ces extrêmes
couplés de chaleur et d'humidité donc
c'est des territoires qui deviennent
quand même tout simplement invivable je
voudrais rester sur cette notion de
d'injustice climatique elle a été très
clairement exprimée par le Premier
ministre
pakistanais c'était devant l'ONU la
semaine dernière
[Musique]
pourquoi mon peuple paie-t-il le prix
d'un changement climatique aussi
important sans que nous en soyons
responsables
nous ne contribuons rien à cette
situation la nature s'est déchaînée sur
le Pakistan sans tenir compte de notre
empreinte carbone qui est quasiment
nulle nos actions n'ont pas contribué à
cela
il est donc tout à fait raisonnable
d'attendre une certaine forme de justice
pour ses pertes et ses dommages
sans parler d'une meilleure
reconstruction avec résilience et force
[Musique]
qui est venu en aide au Pakistan là
très concrètement depuis le début de
cette crise la France a déployé des
secours de première urgence et des
secouristes beaucoup de pays notamment
des pays du Golfe Persique où il y a une
grande communauté
expatriée pakistanaise comme on le sait
les États-Unis bien sûr
d'ailleurs le premier ministre est
soumise à faire étrangère le fils buto
ont passé beaucoup de temps aux
États-Unis ces derniers jours pour
justement attirer l'attention de la
communauté
internationale autour des problèmes du
Pakistan faut pas perdre de vue une
chose c'est que déjà avant même
s'ilondation selon les chiffres du
Programme alimentaire mondial 43 % de la
population
souffrait disposition à la sécurité
alimentaire
38% des enfants de moins de 5 ans
souffrait de retard de croissance donc
on est en disant un pays affaibli
finalement
physiquement presque quasiment on peut
pas dire que oui physiquement
ok il faut venir en aide une des
demandes du Pakistan c'est d'ailleurs
notamment que le pays est
malheureusement assez endetté et que il
y ait un assouplissement et un
rachelonnement de la Châtelet alors vous
l'avez évoqué rapidement tout à l'heure
mais je voudrais qu'on rentre en détail
sur toujours à propos des conséquences
diplomatiques de de cette catastrophe
vous liée Laetitia souligner on va dire
un début de réchauffement entre la
France et le Pakistan et donc illustré
par cette rencontre entre manuel Macron
et le Premier ministre pakistanais
c'était en marge de l'Assemblée générale
des Nations unies tout à l'heure
monsieur c'est vrai que c'est un geste
diplomatique assez fort alors bien sûr
la France a renouvelé sa promesse d'aide
l'humanitaire et matériel mais aussi la
nomination d'un ambassadeur du Pakistan
en France et ça oui c'est un signal de
réchauffement entre les deux pays oui
alors ça se fait il faut le rappeler
dans un climat qui était avant cela très
tendu entre la France et le Pakistan le
froid avait été jeté en 2020 pourquoi
parce que la caricature du prophète
Mahomet était ressorti en France à
l'occasion de l'ouverture du procès des
attentats de Charlie Hebdo en 2015 et
ensuite il y a eu les deux discours
d'Emmanuel Macron l'hommage à Samuel
Paty assassiné à Confluence à Honorine
et puis le discours de la Sorbonne sur
les séparatismes et à la suite de ces
événements il y a eu des manifestations
ultra-violes anti-française qui se sont
succédés au Pakistan inquiété
instrumentalisé par un mouvement
islamiste très influent la balle
TLP et qui demandait par exemple le
boycott des produits français et le
renvoi de l'ambassadeur français le café
finalement pas eu lieu Paris avait quand
même rappelé une quinzaine de diplomates
c'est ça oui c'était en avril 2021
c'était une mesure préventive car il y
avait des menaces d'attentat qui était
envisageables d'ailleurs en mai le Sénat
avait auditionné marque berati
l'ambassadeur français islamada qui
avait déclaré c'était une audition à
huis clos je précise l'ambassadeur avait
déclaré sur le plan politique nous avons
eu le sentiment quand s'en prenant à la
France et à son président les plus
hautes autorités pakistanaises ont en
quelque sorte donner le feu vert à une
campagne anti française et c'est vrai
qu'à l'époque il faut s'en rappeler de
ces mots très violents par exemple de la
ministre des Droits de l'homme qui avait
affirmé Macron fait aux musulmans ce que
les nazis infligeaient aux Juifs voilà
on a les lois le président pakistanais
avait estimé que le projet de loi sur le
séparatisme
français portaient atteinte aux
musulmans du monde entier donc il faut
aussi à l'aune de cette mémoire récente
finalement on a une mémoire courte mais
c'était il y a deux ans il faut
comprendre peut-être l'engagement que
certains jugent modestes de la France
dans l'aide qu'elle apporte au Pakistan
Gilles boquera
on en est où des relations entre la
France et le Pakistan aujourd'hui et
qu'est-ce que ça peut changer dans
justement cet engagement d'aide
française après après les inondations
pendant ces innovations parce que c'est
pas fini oui parce qu'effectivement
comme ça vient d'être appelé la relation
a été extrêmement tendue ces trois
quatre dernières années entre les deux
pays brancan d'ailleurs le premier
ministre pakistanais sortant maintenant
n'avait rien fait pour calmer apaiser
les tensions entre les deux pays sur la
question des caricatures on a rappelé
effectivement ce parti le terrier qu'il
abeille Pakistan qui a fait la défense
de Léonard de prophète son fonds de
commerce
c'est un parti qui a une capacité à
faire descendre les gens dans la rue
surtout étalement ils essaient
maintenant de partie PSG de Sion c'est
pas un parti qui pèse électoralement
mais
qui pèse sur les esprits si vous voulez
et effectivement là c'est un tournant
parce que la rencontre entre le
président Macron et le Premier ministre
pakistanais est un tournant et marque un
certain réchauffement entre les deux
pays ça et ça se ressent aussi dans dans
les médias c'est-à-dire que le fait que
la France est aidé parce qu'il y a une
aide internationale j'imagine qu'il y a
beaucoup de pays qui sont mobilisés
peut-être pas qu'il y a un focus fait
par des médias pakistanais sur ce que la
France est en train de réaliser là-bas
non évidemment ce qui est important tous
les paquetaires c'est là que peut
apporter les États-Unis encore une fois
si on parlait avec la relation entre la
France et le Pakistan était tendu ça en
était de même alors la relation entre
les États-Unis et le Pakistan du temps
libre carnet et là aussi il y a un être
honnête net des crispation entre les
deux pays alors je parlais de diplomatie
de la catastrophe justement vous
référence aux États-Unis je vous propose
une séquence assez édifiante qui
concerne le secrétaire d'État américain
Anthony minken mon équivalent de notre
ministre d'affaires étrangères qui s’est
rendu au Pakistan vous allez bien
écouter ce qu'il dit et ensuite la
réponse de son homologue pakistanais
regardez
j'ai exhorté nos collègues à solliciter
la Chine à propos des questions
importantes d'allègement et de
restructuration de la dette afin que le
Pakistan puisse se remettre au plus vite
des inondations je suis déjà engagé dans
des conversations des conversations très
productives avec la Chine qui a déjà
offert un soutien énorme non seulement
sous la forme d'aide mais aussi en ce
qui concerne nos paiements je pense
qu'il est plus productif de se
concentrer sur les relations bilatérales
de chacun je laisserai mes conversations
à la Chine entre moi et la Chine j'ai le
bocage reste avec vous parce que c'est
quand même assez étonnant de voir que en
pleine catastrophe humanitaire
catastrophe climatique finalement il y a
toujours le bras de fer entre les
États-Unis et la Chine qui s'invite dans
les dans les conversations c'est à dire
que la Chine est maintenant le premier
partenaire du Pakistan en termes de
d'assistance militaire de vente d'armes
d'investissement privé il y a le fameux
projet de corridor économique
Pakistan ou dans lequel la Chine a mis
60 milliards de dollars
donc et le la Chine bon à ses intérêts
propres dans cerclement de l'Inde en
s'appuyant sur le Pakistan mais c'est
vrai que là aussi on a un affrontement
Chine Etats-Unis au Pakistan et le
Pakistan plutôt les États-Unis c'est de
regagner pied au Pakistan à travers
le nouveau gouvernement dirigé par
chabachary
la menace terroriste sur les territoires
occidentaux
[Musique]
ce qui tient suffisamment compte de
ce défi climatique majeur j'aimerais
vous proposer une réponse magique en 2
minutes qu'on pourrait appliquer des
notes sorties du plateau mais
malheureusement ça n'existe pas et en
fait ce qu'il faut faire c'est
effectivement je suis de je pense que le
défi climatique aujourd'hui n'est pas
encore n'est pas encore complètement
intégré au-delà de des logiques Nord-Sud
au logique de développement
international c'est-à-dire que vous vous
avez des typiquement dans les banques de
développement on se sent entre d'abord
sur le développement économique et
ensuite on y ajoute ce qu'on appelle du
coup le développement durable qui vient
en seconde main et là la difficulté dans
des cas comme pas comme le Pakistan mais
vous avez pareil ce cas beaucoup en
Afrique subsaharienne en partie en
Amérique en Amérique du Sud de pouvoir
construire immédiatement des
infrastructures qui soient résilientes
pas seulement économiquement mais
écologiquement et ça c'est pas simple et
c'est quelque chose qui c'est des
compétences qui manquent aussi c'est pas
seulement le fait que ce soit pas
intellectuellement intégré c'est que on
a des compétences aujourd'hui qui ne
sont pas encore présentes parce que les
gens qui sont formés au développement
international et moi je l'ai été ne sont
pas formé nécessairement à ces enjeux là
donc il y a tout le long de la chaîne de
développement vous avez cet effort-là à
faire de formes et légendes d'appliquer
ces processus là et une fine évidemment
d'obtenir les financements nécessaires
parce qu'on en revient toujours et on en
reviendra toujours dans le cas de au
moins au début pour lancer la transition
climatique à cette question là du
essentiel du financement et alors cette
catastrophe au Pakistan elle est
malheureusement passionnante à décoder
parce qu'il y a tous ces tous ces
leviers finalement et tous ces files
attirés et notamment j'en reviens à
votre expertise de climatologue le cycle
de l'eau qu'est-ce qu'elle nous apprend
sur ce site qui est en train de devenir
assez chaotique en fait c'est exactement
ça en fait on sait que dans les régions
équatoriales la variabilité du cycle de
l'eau va augmenter c'est ça va être de
plus en plus chaotique d'une année à
l'autre c'est à dire qu'on va devoir
faire face à des événements complètement
différents et qui vont s'enchaîner d'une
année à l'autre et on sait aussi que
cette variabilité elle augmente beaucoup
plus fortement et intensément que le
réchauffement lui-même donc ça complique
quand même énormément les choses on sait
aussi que dans ces régions là il y a
toujours une part de la variabilité
climatique naturelle qui est là et donc
des fois c'est difficile de décortiquer
ce qui est attribuable au changement
climatique et ceux qui ne l'est pas et
puis dans certaines régions c'est pas
forcément le cas du Pakistan et de
l'Inde mais on sait que la variabilité
du cycle de l'eau va aussi être plus
intense à l'intérieur d'une saison par
exemple si on prend le cas de l'Amérique
du Sud on sait qu'on va avoir de longues
périodes sans pluie et puis quand il va
se mettre à pleuvoir il va vraiment
pleuvoir énormément et donc là on change
vraiment le cycle de l'eau sur beaucoup
d'échelle de temps merci beaucoup merci
à tous les trois d'avoir à tous les
quatre d'avoir participé à ce débat je
rappelle Gilles boquera le titre de
votre livre publié aux éditions
tallendier le Pakistan en
100 questions merci encore et à bientôt
sur sur Public Sénat je vous dis à lundi
pour un nouveau numéro de sens public
avec un petit zoom avant radical mais
c'est bien ça donne la pêche et puis
demain matin c'est à 8h c'est dans la
matinale elle reçoit ses cils Duflot
directrice générale donc ça France merci
[Musique]